hi herzlich willkommen bei ZDF heute
live schön dass ihr dabei seid wir
sprechen hier heute über ein ziemlich
großes Thema wir sprechen nämlich über
die aktuelle Lage der deutschen
Wirtschaft das habt Ihr sicher schon
mitbekommen die wird in den letzten
Tagen und Wochen ziemlich viel
diskutiert und das von sehr
verschiedenen Seiten auch sehr
unterschiedlich heute erst verkündete
das Wirtschaftsministerium in den
kommenden Monaten sei keine Belebung der
Wirtschaft in Sicht das Ägypten Blick
auf die neuesten Zahlen zu Produktion zu
unseren Exporten und Aufträgen und die
deutschen Unternehmer die schlagen noch
viel größeren Alarm so hat die deutsche
Industrie und Handelskammer jetzt davor
gewarnt dass immer mehr deutsche Firmen
ins Ausland abwandern würden weil hier
in Deutschland zu produzieren einfach zu
teuer würde und auch andere
Wirtschaftsverbände und Experte in waren
aktuell in Deutschland haben wir eine
der höchsten Abgabe Lasten ansteuern für
Unternehmen wir haben eine überbordende
Bürokratie Fachkräftemangel und
Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz ihr seht ihn
hier schon hinter mir der bekräftigte im
ZDF sommerinterview gegenüber Protokoll
das ist der hauptstadtstudioleiter des
ZDF erneut das Deutschland ein Wachstum
befürchte ich habe das bezogen auf die
Möglichkeiten die mit all den
Investitionen verbunden sind in den
Ausbau der erneuerbaren Energien der
Stromnetze der
wasserstoffnetze des der
Wasserstoffproduktion die wir in
Deutschland brauchen den Umbau vieler
Teile unserer Wirtschaften das steht ja
auch alles konkret bevor viele planen
und wir sorgen dafür dass das jetzt auch
möglich wird mit einem ganz neuen Tempo
beim Ausbau der Stromerzeugung über
windkraft und Solarenergie Biomasse
Wasserkraft ich glaube dass das eine
Wirkung haben wird auf die ganze
Wirtschaft
ja was Olaf Scholz hier sagt wirkt auf
jeden Fall anders als das was aktuell
viele Zahlen sagen lasst uns da mal
drauf gucken die deutsche Wirtschaft ist
jetzt nämlich drei Quartal lang nicht
mehr gewachsen und teils geschrumpft und
hier sehen wir die Zahlen vom
Internationalen Währungsfonds der
erwartet dass die deutsche Wirtschaft
auch insgesamt in diesem Jahr nicht
wachsen wird sondern wie wir sie hier
sehen als einziges schrumpfen wird mit
dieser Negativentwicklung steht
Deutschland ihr seht es an den Zahlen
aktuell im internationalen Vergleich
ziemlich alleine da und deswegen wollen
wir uns heute fragen wie es zu diesem
unterschiedlichen Einschätzungen kommt
und warum der Bundeskanzler aktuell die
Lage so anders einschätzt wir wollen uns
fragen
ignoriert Olaf Scholz die Krise und das
wollen wir diskutieren und natürlich wie
immer nicht alleine sondern mit tollen
Gästen zum einen mit Professorin Ulrike
malmedia sie ist Professorin in wirklich
und Wirtschaftsweise für die
Bundesregierung und Heike freuen sie ist
Geschäftsführerin des Startups Marvel
Fusion mit Sitz in München und natürlich
möchten wir auch wie immer mit euch
darüber sprechen wenn ihr Fragen zum
Thema habt oder Anmerkungen vielleicht
habt ihr ja auch eigene Erfahrungen aus
der Wirtschaft die ihr mit Euch mit uns
teilen wollt wie es euch gerade an eurem
Arbeitsplatz geht was eure Gefühle dazu
sind macht das wie immer gerne meldet
euch einfach hier im Youtube Chat oder
per Mail an die jetzt eingeblendete
Adresse so jetzt spreche ich aber
erstmal mit Professorin Ulrike meinem
dir über die Äußerungen von Scholz aus
dem Sommer Interview und ihre Sicht auf
die aktuelle Lage und damit ihr euch ein
bisschen eingrüben könnt stellen wir sie
euch einmal kurz vor
Ulrike mal mit dir gilt als eine der
wichtigsten ÖkonomInnen der Welt die
studierte Juristin und
volkswirtschaftlerin ist Professorin für
finanzmarktökonomie an der University of
California in Berkley seit August 2022
ist sie zudem eine der fünf sogenannten
Wirtschaftsweisen ein Gremium dass die
Bundesregierung berät im Interview mit
der Wirtschaftswoche sagte sie kürzlich
Deutschland habe beste Voraussetzungen
für neues Wachstum man müsse aber
mutiger dynamischer und hier und da auch
drastischer werden
ja und da ist sie uns direkt
zugeschaltet guten Abend Frau
Professorin die ja schön dass Sie bei
uns sind
guten Morgen aus Kalifornien wenn ich
das so sagen darf das stimmt wir bewegen
uns in unterschiedlichen Zeitzonen dir
wie blicken sie denn auf diese
Äußerungen von Scholz der hat ja wie wir
gerade eben gehört haben gesagt die
Energiewende werde Auswirkungen auf die
gesamte Wirtschaft haben wir würden uns
insgesamt in einem langfristigen
Aufschwung befinden dass irritiert ja
gerade viele
ja in den Medien dominieren natürlich
derzeit vor allen Dingen die negativen
Einschätzung die Einschätzung das im
letzten Quartal und wahrscheinlich auch
vorausschauendes keine positiven
Wachstumszahlen geben wird allerdings
würde ich da ganz kurz mal eine kleine
Pause einlegen wollen und sagen bei
dieser Diskussion vergessen wir auch das
ist auch daher kommt dass wir durch die
Energiekrise im letzten Jahr sehr viel
besser durchgekommen sind als wir das
gedacht hatten es gab ja schon Stimmen
die sagen es gibt einen totalen Einbruch
bis zu -6 %.b das nicht passiert und
wenn das nicht passiert ist heißt das
dass wir auch nicht so viel aufholer
Effekt haben nicht so viele Effekt und
deswegen dieser Unterschied was hat die
Wachstumsrate ist nicht so positiv sein
kann also das stört mich immer so ein
klein bisschen an der Diskussion wenn
dann direkt von die Industrialisierung
kranker Mann Europas und so geredet wird
ich würde auch gerne ab und zu mal sagen
wow wir sind als Industrienation da
ziemlich gut hindurchgekommen
was jetzt trotzdem diesen Kontrast
betrifft den ich überhaupt nicht klein
reden will stimmt es dass die Zahlen im
Augenblick nicht toll aussehen teilweise
ist es konjunkturell und teilweise gibt
es Mittel und langfristige Probleme die
angegangen werden müssen wir Scholz sehe
ich echte Chancen für unser Land aber
vielleicht etwas abweichen von Herrn
Scholz ist Meinung glaube ich schon das
drastischere Entscheidung
Experimente mit neuen Industrien und
Vereinfachungen gewagt werden müssen
dass wir dorthin kommen
sie blicken also ein Stück drastischer
auf die Lage als Olaf Scholz sagen es
braucht drastische Aktion was wäre denn
das ganz konkret was müssen wir uns
darunter vorstellen
vielleicht kann man sagen radikale
Zukunftsorientierung dass wir uns
überlegen wenn wir Wachstum erreichen
wollen in welchen Sparten können wir das
erreichen und das sind auch aber nicht
nur Sparten in denen wir traditionell
stark gewesen sind die unsere Wirtschaft
getragen haben also Maschinenbau
Automobil Chemie davon gibt es bestimmt
viele Aspekte wo ich sehr hoffe dass
deren eigene Zukunftsorientierung und
weiterbringen wird aber ab und zu auch
auf Ideen setzen die sich vielleicht
nicht so schnell umsetzen kann also wenn
ich bei den traditionellen Industrien
mal bleiben dürfte
Automobil da beweise ich halt nach wie
vor dass Deutschland nicht die führende
Industrie bei den Elektroautos geworden
ist woran liegt das man hat sich gedacht
also interpretiere ich jetzt mal so
hinein dass dieser Verbrennung Motor ja
ziemlich gut funktioniert nach wie vor
Absatz findet der Name ja deutsche
grande der deutschen Autofirmen zieht
weltweit also hängen wir doch ein
bisschen an diesen alten frühen fest und
schöpfen die aus solange es geht statt
zu sagen jetzt fragen wir es einfach mal
da rein zu gehen wir Wagens uns mehr mit
autonomen driving auseinanderzusetzen
auch wenn wir befürchtet vielleicht
mögen dass die Deutschen und andere
Nationen nicht so und gucken mal was
dazu holen ist das nächste könnte schon
Motor sein ja ich weiß nicht wie sehr
die automobilformen an so etwas arbeiten
diese
Schritte einzugehen die möglicherweise
auch zu Verlusten führen das ist
zunächst mal was auf der
privatwirtschaftlichen Seite und das
möchte ich auch sehr betonen ich finde
nur immer vom Staat sofort wenn Sie
nicht der richtige Ansatz sondern auch
zu überlegen wie könnte er vielleicht
noch denken in der Wirtschaft ein
bisschen umgeschaltet werden
von der staatlichen Seite die Sie heute
hier interessiert ähm heißt es aber auch
sich genau zu überlegen bei jedem Euro
von Subvention die ich in traditionelle
Industrien und Produktion hereinstecke
mich zu fragen wer das nicht in junge
innovative Unternehmen investiert wer
das nicht besser in Ausbau der
energiekapazitäten investiert wer das
nicht besser investiert mehr Fachkräfte
an zu werden die sowohl in den Behörden
einschließlich der Ausländerämter als
auch in den Unternehmen dafür sorgen
würde dass der
Wachstumsfaktor der uns fehlt nämlich
das Personal endlich wieder anziehen
kann
ja über die Möglichkeiten von privatem
Kapital sprechen wir gleich noch mal
lassen Sie uns mal kurz auf große
direkte Investitionen schauen die ist ja
laut Olaf Scholz aktuell schon gibt der
taiwanesische detailanesische Hersteller
TSMC will ein Halbleiterwerk in Dresden
bauen und bekommt dafür mehr als 10
Milliarden an Investitionen die Hälfte
dieser Förderung kommt aktuell dann vom
Staat in Tablet 30 Milliarden in
Magdeburg investieren bekommt dafür
wahrscheinlich 10 Milliarden vom Staat
das klingt doch eigentlich nach großem
Investitionsvolumen oder
in der Tat das ist sehr großes
Investitionsvolumen und ab und an machen
wir diese sehr großen Zahlen im
Vergleich zur größeres Bundeshaushaltes
durchaus ein bisschen Sorgen allerdings
wurde ich aus meiner Perspektive im
Großen und Ganzen sagen das klingt
strategisch vernünftig das ist jetzt
einmal den Versuch wert zu schauen ob
man diese Industrie hier anziehen kann
aufbauen kann Wertschöpfungsketten da
bildet sich auch dann drumherum was an
Startups und ähm
angrenzenden Industrien ob sich daraus
vielleicht neues Wachstum schaffen lässt
allerdings wäre mir ganz wichtig da
nicht einfach nur Meinung zu haben war
das jetzt zu viel Geld das da
reingesteckt wird oder war das genau
richtig und ähm und dann nicht weiter zu
evaluieren sondern versuchen
wissenschaftlich da dran zu gehen und
das kann man kann sich anschauen wie
denn in einem Jahr in fünf Jahren in 10
Jahren in Magdeburg oder Dresden sich
die wirtschaftliche Situation verändert
hat wie sieht man Zuzug aus wie sieht es
mit den Steuern aus wie sieht es im
Umland aus und in der eigentlichen
ähm und das zu versuchen zu vergleichen
die Ökonomen sagen würden also versuchen
zu vergleichen mit vielleicht einer
Stadt von ähnlicher Größe und ähnlichen
ausmerzen wo ähm wo ist diese
Unterstützung nicht gegeben hat und dann
können wir sehen was die 10 Milliarden
wert wenn das nicht gemacht wird dann
bleiben wir irgendwie im Bereich von
Meinung und nie darauf eingehen können
ob das gut investiert das Geld war
ja wissenschaftliche Evaluierung auf
jeden Fall ein Thema dass wir aber
langfristig anschauen müssen wer sich
jetzt aktuell schon so ein bisschen
darüber beschwert ist ja der deutsche
Mittelstand der sagt jetzt da fließen
super hohe Summen staatlicher Förderung
in quasi das Einfallstor zu deutschen
Wirtschaft was ist eigentlich mit dem
Mittelstand der wegen hohen
Produktionskosten abwandern muss können
Sie das verstehen
das kann ich absolut verstehen und das
hängt auch mit dem Thema dass wir gerade
hatten der Evaluation sehr eng zusammen
ich möchte halt dass wir uns bei jedem
Euro Fragen können wo ist der marginale
nutzen die wir können nun sagen würden
am größten und das ist im Augenblick
sehr schwer zu tun nach wie vor hängt
Deutschland mit aktuellen zeitnahen
Daten von Effekten von
Beschränkungen von Schwierigkeiten im
Mittelstand und in der Großindustrie
unheimlich hinterher das ist ein ganz
wichtiges Thema wo wir deutschen
eigentlich ist führen sein können unser
Effizienz und Organisation
eigentlich auch anwenden können und das
macht mich schon sehr traurig dass das
in Deutschland der schwierig ist und
auch selbst ich in meiner Forschung
deswegen auch lieber andere Länder wo
ich also solche Dinge einfacher
evaluieren kann die Sorgen des
Mittelstandes sind in Anführungsstrichen
zum Glück ähm nicht unbedingt
interessant mit die Themen die jetzt
auch bei den größeren Industrien
diskutiert werden also zum Beispiel
Fachkräftemangel also zum Beispiel
Entbürokratisierung Entschleunigung
Beschleunigung Entschuldigung
Beschleunigung der Genehmigungsverfahren
der Prozesse mehr Planungssicherheit das
sind Themen die für alle Bereiche der
Industrie wichtig sind und da mehr den
Prozess voranzutreiben mehr Energie
hineinzustecken wäre glaube ich für
Deutschland und für jeden jede Sparte
der deutschen Wirtschaft extrem wichtig
ja und passend dazu habe ich hier gerade
auch einen Kommentar aus der Community
der gewissermaßen auf sie reagiert und
zwar sagt ein YouTube User unsere
Politiker tun doch alles dafür dass
Unternehmen und Fachkräfte auseinander
brauchen die sich doch jetzt nicht zu
beschweren lassen Sie uns noch mal auf
das Thema Fachkräfte gucken was er in
Deutschland Stichwort Fachkräftemangel
auch ein wichtiges ist was müsste den
ganz konkret passieren damit mehr
Fachkräfte zu uns kommen oder das Land
eben nicht wieder nach kurzer Zeit
verlassen
genau also
die
Einstellung in Deutschland ist ja
traditionell ein bisschen ja kann man
vielleicht sagen eine leicht abwehrende
gewesen dass wir so ein bisschen die
Befürchtung gehabt haben dass unser Land
eingerannt wird von
von Leuten aus allen möglichen Ländern
und dass wir schauen müssen dass das
auch geordnet ist und gegebenenfalls da
sorgfältig prüfen müssen ob sie etwas
zulässig ist daraus hat sich ein System
ergeben dass die Einwanderung von
Fachkräften sehr schwierig macht wenn
man sich anschaut wie lange es dauert
Anerkennung von Abschluss zu bekommen
oder überhaupt einfach das gesamte
Verfahren bei den Ausländerbehörden die
Einreichung von Unterlagen
und den Prozess um die endgültige zu
bekommen dann ist es schon ein sehr
großes Trauerspiel jetzt möchte ich
nicht sagen jetzt möchte ich hier nicht
die Ausländerbehörde beschimpfen ich
meine ich denke in der Mentalitätswandel
von einer
Behörde zu einer mehr ser orientierten
immigrationsagentur wäre sehr sehr
wichtig das würde ich mir schon wünschen
aber die sind natürlich auch vom
Fachkräftemangel betroffen und es ist
sehr schwierig da die das Tempo zu
beschleunigen ohne dass man die
Unterstützung gibt und zusätzliches
Personal einstellt also dass wir die
erste der erste Aspekt also das
Verfahren vereinfachen in zweiter Aspekt
der glaube ich sehr wichtig wäre wäre
das wenn Leute ins Land gekommen sind
das Leben ja auch attraktiv zu machen
und es möglich zu machen zum Beispiel
als berufstätige Frau zu arbeiten und
trotzdem Betreuung für die Kinder zu
haben in Schule in einem Nachmittag vor
der Schule in der Früh Betreuung das
sind Dimensionen an den Deutschland im
Vergleich zu anderen Ländern nach wie
vor sehr stark arbeiten muss
ja und inwiefern das auch eine
kulturelle Komponente ist darüber möchte
ich mit Ihnen gleich zum Abschluss noch
mal sprechen lassen Sie uns noch mal auf
das Thema
Investitionsvolumen schauen und da
explizit auf den Startup Bereich ich
habe da mal ein paar Zahlen mitgebracht
wir sehen jetzt hier eingeblendet die
Startup Investitionen in Deutschland da
haben wir ein krasses Peak so um 2021
rum und sehen aber mittlerweile hat sich
das Investitionsvolumen quasi halbiert
wie können sie sich das erklären
ich weiß nicht ganz genau welche Zahlen
sie sich da anschauen man muss ja
zwischen verschiedenen Phasen
unterscheiden also zunächst mal gibt es
ich sag mal den
unternehmensfreudigen Maschinenbauer
oder Maschinenbauerin die Idee hatten
Unternehmen zu gründen und jetzt erstmal
die Idee so ein bisschen austestet
ausprobiert da ist die Lage meines
Erachtens nach wie vor in Deutschland
nicht schlecht es ist ein ziemlicher
Paragraphen Dschungel aber in der hin
gibt es staatliche Förderung die
Universitäten zum Beispiel in meiner
Heimatstadt Aachen die habe ich da sind
besser geworden da Mentoringprogramme
aufzulegen ich denke dass da dieser
dieser Anschub Investition gar nicht so
schlecht sind das Problem sich in
Deutschland dort wo so eine Idee sich im
Grunde auszahlt ja und Unternehmer
erfolgreich ist und jetzt mal 100
Millionen oder mehr braucht da haben wir
in Deutschland immer noch nicht die
Struktur dass das fand es gibt die diese
Gelder zur Verfügung stellen können da
fängt dann das Suchen nach Geldern für
weitere Investition en an wie sie
gezeigt haben dann sind es auch
ausländische Geldgeber die da
einspringen weil wir genau diese diese
Finanzierungsstruktur in Deutschland
leider nicht haben und dann fangen die
Unternehmen natürlich an mehr und mehr
Kontakte ins Ausland zu knüpfen und dann
möglicherweise sich ins Ausland
verlagern den gewechselt also die IPO an
der Börse im Ausland zu machen und das
sehe ich als ein absolutes Riesenproblem
in Deutschland jetzt wo wir endlich
unter den Studenten oder der jungen
Generation diese Einstellung haben und
ich will jetzt auch mal probieren was
ich mit meiner Idee machen kann ich
möchte nicht einfach nur ein
traditionelles Unternehmen gehen sondern
vielleicht was neues starten ja was
Wachstum bringen könnte dann muss es
doch irgendwie möglich werden diese
Leute im Land zu behalten und da die
richtige wie sie also welche Kapitel
Industrie mehr ins Leben zu rufen und
fondsstrukturen zu haben
Kapitalsammelstellen zu haben die diese
Unternehmen unterstützen können und
Deutschland attraktiv als aggressives
Land für sie weiter darstellen können
das wäre ein extrem wichtiges Thema für
die deutsche Wirtschaft
ganz herzlichen Dank bis hierhin ich
glaube wir haben alles schon eine Menge
mitgenommen wir sprechen uns gleich noch
mal zum Wirtschaftsstandort Deutschland
danke bis hin
und genau über diese vorstrukturen über
kapitalmöglichkeiten für Unternehmen
dies noch nicht so lange gibt für
Startups über die möchte ich jetzt
sprechen und zwar mit Heike freuen sie
ist Geschäftsführerin von Marvel Fusion
das ist selber ein Start-up und damit
ihr wisst mit wem ist hier zu tun haben
stellen wir sie euch jetzt einmal vor
das Münchner Unternehmen Marvel Fusion
will die Kernfusion kommerzialisieren
das Startup das 2019 gegründet wurde
möchte die Produktion von vollkommen
nachhaltiger Energie ermöglichen doch
eine Testanlage baut das Unternehmen
trotz früherer Überlegungen nicht etwa
in Deutschland sondern an der
US-amerikanischen Colorado State
University
Geschäftsführerin von Marvel Fusion ist
Heike Freund sie findet in Deutschland
und Europa sollte mehr Geld in solche
sogenannten detect-themen fließen sonst
bestünde die Gefahr dass man den
Anschluss an China und die USA verliert
und da ist sie uns jetzt zugeschaltet
hallo Frau Freund schön dass Sie bei uns
sind hallo schönen guten Abend aus
München ja das ist eigentlich ganz
wunderbar wir haben eben mit Frau Mann
dir gesprochen an was ist der
start-up-branche gerade fehlt hier in
Deutschland und da kam vor allem die
direkt auf vorstrukturen auf
Förderstrukturen für Startups und sie
haben jetzt seit junges ist da der
entschieden ihre Versuchsanlage für
Kernfusion nicht etwa in Deutschland zu
bauen sondern in Colorado wie kam es
dazu
genau also vielleicht kurz dazu wir sind
eine Münchner Firma wir haben hier ein
komplett neuartigen Ansatz zu
Kommerzialisierung der Kernfusion
entwickelt die Kernfusion ist das
Gegenteil der Kernspaltung bei der
Kernfusion entstehen kein langlebiger
radioaktiver Abfall kein
Sicherheitsrisiko ist eine CO2-freie
Energiequelle also genau die
Energiequelle die wir eigentlich auch
für den Wirtschaftsstandort Deutschland
in der Zukunft bräuchten und nachdem wir
viele erfolgreiche Experimente bisher
schon durchgeführt haben über 2000
erfolgreiche Experimente durchgeführt
haben stand jetzt für uns der große
Schritt an wo bauen wir einen
Technologie Demonstrator und hier haben
wir uns jetzt entschieden in
Partnerschaft mit der Colorado State
University in Colorado diese Testanlage
zu bauen hier hatten wir eine sehr
unternehmerische Universität die mit uns
gemeinsam in diese lasertestanlage
investieren wird in USA nennt man das so
schön Public Private Partnership also
eine Partnerschaft zwischen einer
Universität und einem privat
wissenschaftlichen Unternehmen ich
glaube gerade im deep-tech-bereich in
dem wir ja aktiv sind sind das extrem
wichtige Instrumente umso Themen auch
zeitnah in die Kommerzialisierung zu
bringen also haben wir uns entschieden
diese Testanlage jetzt in den USA zu
bauen das noch kein endgültiges nein für
den Standort München und Deutschland
also unser Headquarter bleibt in München
ein Großteil unserer Mitarbeiter bleiben
in München insbesondere unsere Forschung
wird in München bleiben aber diesen
Schritt der Testanlage werden wir jetzt
mit der Colorado State University bauen
der Schritt danach wäre dann der
Prototyp eines ähm eine
laserfusionskraftwerkes und hier sind
wir weiterhin engen Austausch mit der
Politik in Bayern Deutschland Europa und
hoffen dass wir den Schritt auch wieder
in Deutschland gehen können
also eine Kooperation eines Start-ups
mit einer Universität in den USA die wie
sie gesagt haben eine sehr
unternehmerisch geprägte Universität ist
gibt es die nicht in Deutschland
in Deutschland ist das Forschungsumfeld
noch deutlich monolithischer also wir
sehen gerade in dem Maßstab des eine
Partnerschaft über das Volumen von 150
Millionen Dollar das sehen wir in der
Form in Deutschland nicht das auch
infusionsumfeld es gibt ca 40
privatwirtschaftliche Firmen weltweit
davon ungefähr eine Hand von Europa ist
das mit Abstand die größte Partnerschaft
mit einer Universität und in dem Rahmen
haben die amerikanischen Universitäten
hier deutlich sind deutlich
unternehmerischer haben deutlich
stärkere Instrumente zur Verfügung als
ich das in Deutschland gesehen habe und
da vielleicht auch noch mal die
Anknüpfung zu Professorin Marvin die er
gerade ich bin voll bei ihr und
unterstütze die Aussage dass es für
Unternehmen und Startups in Deutschland
gerade Technologie getriebene
Unternehmen und Startups die erste Phase
also was man dann Theorie oder eine Seat
Finanzierung nennt hier haben wir sehr
sehr gute Instrumente in Deutschland
hier haben wir gerade an den
Universitäten wir sind in München ich
kenne die Unternehmertum hier gut sehr
sehr gute Programme die quasi diesen
ersten Schritt unterstützen wenn es dann
aber um das Thema
großfinanzierung geht also der nächste
Schritt wo man mehrere hundert Millionen
Euro bräuchte um in physische
Infrastruktur zu investieren hier fehlt
es aktuell an den richtigen Instrumenten
in Deutschland und da unterstützt sich
sehr die Aussage von Professoren mal mit
dir dass man hier rein arbeiten muss
dass diese Schritte dann auch in
Deutschland gegangen werden können
ja sie sagen es gerade insbesondere wenn
es um sehr hohe geldsum geht die aber
wichtig sind für künftige Innovationen
investieren viele Unternehmen
mittlerweile im Ausland und nicht mehr
in Deutschland und Bundeskanzler Olaf
Scholz der hat im ZDF sommerinterview
darin kein Problem gesehen was
ärgert mich auch in jedem
volkswirtschaftskurs lernen die
Studenten und Studenten dass der Erfolg
einer erfolgswirtschaft darin gesehen
werden kann dass ihre Unternehmen auch
im Ausland investieren nun muss ich ab
und zu hören und lesen dass das
angeblich schlecht sind gut
ja eigentlich gut dass die jetzt erstmal
ins Ausland gehen würden Sie dem
zustimmen
also ich glaube grundsätzlich in unserem
Fall sehe ich uns als globale Firma wir
wollen ein Riesenthema in die Realität
umsetzen fusions Energie als CO2-freie
sicheres saubere Energiequelle das ist
ein Riesenthema und als als
Geschäftsführerin einer Firma suche ich
natürlich global die besten Standorte um
das zu tun und die besten
Partnerschaften und die besten
Rahmenbedingungen werde immer dorthin
gehen wo die besten Rahmenbedingungen
sind und jetzt sind wir den Schritt
gegangen dass wir in den USA für diese
lasertestanlage die besten
Rahmenbedingungen gefunden haben ich
hoffe dass wir sie für den Schritt
danach auch wieder hier in Deutschland
finden am besten hier in Bayern finden
denn eins muss man ja sagen in
Deutschland haben wir
hervorragende Ingenieure hervorragende
Physiker wir haben ein tolles Team hier
in München aufgebaut wir haben auch sehr
starke Partnerschaft mit der Industrie
aufgebaut mit Siemens Energy z.B um
gemeinsam schon die Kraftwerk
Technologien zu entwickeln mit führenden
Laser Herstellern mit führenden
Materialwissenschaften und und ähnlichem
also es gibt hier ein tolles
industrielles Netzwerk es gibt hier
tolle und klüge Köpfe wir brauchen aber
jetzt die richtigen Instrumente und
Anreizsysteme das am Ende die Ideen dann
auch hier in Deutschland umgesetzt
werden können
Stichwort richtige Instrumente wenn wir
ihr Zitat jetzt den entsprechenden
Personen in der Bundesregierung vorlegen
würden würden die wahrscheinlich sagen
naja wir als Bundesregierung haben am
27.02.2022 ja die sogenannte
start-up-strategie verabschiedet da
stand drin mehr Wachstumskapital bessere
Anwerbungen von Talenten aus dem Ausland
einfachere Ausgründung von Unis das ist
ja auch das was sie gerade beschreiben
inwiefern spürt man denn davon schon
etwas gerade in ihrem Segment also im
deepack Segment
also ich glaube gerade im Deep taxigment
gibt es hier noch Nachbesserungsbedarf
und das liegt insbesondere da drin
anreizinstrumente zu schaffen um genau
diese nächsten Sprünge also nach der
anfangs
Investitionen gehen zu können und vor
allem wenn es darum geht physische
Infrastruktur aufzubauen hier sehe ich
im Ausland zum Beispiel in Frankreich
aber auch in den USA zum Beispiel
Instrumente wie meilensteinbasierte
Förderinstrumente das auch für private
Investoren immer ein extrem
interessanter Hebel und schafften extrem
Anreiz für ein private für private
Investoren dann wie Frau mal mit dir
gegeben genannt hat die richtigen vor
Strukturen aufzubauen und das dann auch
in dem was wir dann zivil und die UCI
nennen also wenn die großen Beträge
notwendig werden hier für die richtigen
Themen haben und ich möchte hier nicht
nur auf den Start zeigen und sagen dass
der Staat ähm all diese Investitionen
stemmen muss aber der Staat muss die
richtigen Anreize setzen und das können
zum Beispiel Meilenstein basierte
Programme Förderprogramme sein das
können aber auch in den gerade in
England sehe ich gute Modelle wo der
Staat Infrastruktur zur Verfügung stellt
Gebäude zur Verfügung gestellt Land zur
Verfügung stellt und dann an Unternehmen
wieder vermietet dass ein interessantes
Modell also diese ich glaube hier müssen
wir deutlich kreativer werden und
vielleicht auch drastischer werden was
solche Themen angeht ein gutes man darf
ja auch nicht nur sich beschweren es
gibt auch gute Elemente hier zum
Beispiel die Agentur für Sprung
Innovation über die wir auch schon eine
Förderung bekommen haben für unsere
laserentwicklung ist glaube ich ein ganz
ganz wichtiger Hebel den in Deutschland
im Portfolio jetzt aufgebaut hat und
solche Hebel gilt es weiter auszubauen
und weiter zu stärken
ja Stichwort im Meer Kreativität das ist
ja etwas was im ganzen
Wirtschaftsstandort betrifft das hat
vielleicht auch etwas mit Kultur zu tun
und das wollen wir jetzt noch mal zu
dritt diskutieren und an dieser Stelle
hole ich noch mal Frau Mann in dir dazu
um mit ihnen beiden sie sind beide
Experten in ihrem Gebiet ähm über die
generellen Unterschiede zwischen den
Standorten USA und Deutschland sprechen
die was haben denn die USA zuletzt
politisch gemacht um ihr Wachstum
anzukurbeln diese geopolitische
Krisensituation in der wir uns jetzt
seit einiger Zeit befinden die hat ja
auch vor den USA nicht Halt gemacht was
haben die darauf folgen besonders gut
gemacht gerade politisch
ja ich weiß gar nicht ob besonders gut
gemacht aber was an was wir jetzt
vielleicht gerade alle denken sind diese
großen politischen Entscheidungen
Flächen redakt und vorher auch chipsart
Jobs Akt da wurden ganz groß angelegte
wirtschaftspolitische Maßnahmen
angesetzt wo bestimmte Industrien mit
großen Summen gefördert werden
das ist ein bisschen vergleichbar
vielleicht was in kleineren Maße jetzt
irgendwie in Magdeburg und Dresden
passiert was mich da besonders aufhören
lässt ist nicht so sehr der
unterschiedliche Umfang der Summen
sondern wie es unterschiedlich in
Deutschland versus Amerika diskutiert
wird also geht jetzt hier z.B im
Augenblick mit dem Chip in den in den
USA den große Summen in ja im Internet
im Wesentlichen rein damit halt ähm
Halbleiterproduktion wieder auf
amerikanischen Boden passiert vielen
Beobachtern ist völlig klar dass sie
hinter der terminesischen Firma
praktisch unerreichbar hinterherhinken
also
und und erreichbar sind und trotzdem
wird gesagt das ist jetzt einfach
strategisch wichtig dass wir diese Fabs
wieder auch American soil haben Ende der
Ende der Diskussion da gibt es gewisse
Ineffizienzen das machen wir jetzt
einfach das heißt das strategische
Denken wird jetzt akzeptiert und dann
wird das durchgezogen und bei uns wird
einerseits als ähm klar wurde was so
dieser domestic requirements vom ICE
sind große aufschreiben in Europa wir
können die Amerikaner das machen sollen
wir dagegenhalten und wenn jetzt
Deutschland mal was macht wird mit der
mit der Sami Kontakte Firma und die mit
mit Internet sind auch wieder direkt
kritisch also das das möchte ich einfach
mal betonen dass das ähm die
strategischen Überlegung diese
langfristigen Überlegung halt nicht
immer das Beste sein werden da wird es
Verluste geben und jetzt müssen wir
jetzt einfach mal ausprobieren der
zweite Kultur jetzt wirklich mehr
kulturelle Unterschied ist dass die
Wirtschaftspolitik hier in Amer da
wirklich ganz klar
letzten Endes America first ist das
haben wir viel mit Trump assoziiert aber
im Grunde ist das ganz egal welche
Administration wir gerade haben da wird
geschaut was ist wichtig für Amerika für
die amerikanische Wirtschaft und wenn
das mit ins staatlich Unterstützung
passieren kann dann passiert halt mit
Steinchen Unterstützung da finde ich
eigentlich in Europa sehr gut dass wir
einen sehr marktorientiertes denken
haben dass sich Sorgen macht und
Wettbewerbsverzerrung dass ich Sorgen
macht das Milliarden und aber Milliarden
in ineffiziente veraltete Industrien
gesteckt werden können dass es
Mitnahmeeffekte gibt darunter wird hier
in Amerika durchaus noch zu leiden sein
würde ich und würden viele Experten auf
dem Gebiet Vorhersagen auch was zum
Beispiel den ARD betrifft insofern sehe
ich das nicht so dass die USA jetzt
unbedingt nur das leuchtende Vorbild
sind ein letztes was ich noch dazu
ich möchte bei dem Thema kulturelle
Unterschiede die Frau Freund eben auch
schon ansprach geht es ja wirklich nicht
nur um staatliche Förderprogramme oder
staatliche Investitionen also wieder
zurück zum Thema BC Industrie was
passiert mit den erfolgreichen
Unternehmen in Deutschland die jetzt mal
100 Millionen 150 Millionen brauchen und
wir in Deutschland haben einfach nicht
die kapitalmarktstruktur das zu liefern
das ist im Wesentlichen
privatwirtschaftliches System ein
natürlich mit staatlichen
Rahmenbedingungen also wenn wir es
geschafft hätten endlich die europäische
kapitalmarktunion voranzutreiben die
Harmonisierung zwischen den Ländern
können wir ein ganz starker Global
Player sein und helfen diese Industrie
aufzubauen auch Themen wie
Pensionskassen haben wir haben vor
kurzem auch als Sachverständigenrat ähm
vier von uns allen eine Meinung
herausgegeben dazu das bringen Kapital
gedeckte Altersversorgung braucht die
dann wiederum so ein staatlichen vor wie
vielen anderen Länder in Amerika aber
auch Schweden zum Beispiel benötigte
diese Kapitalsammelstellen können dann
investieren in diese Industrie es gibt
auch durchaus die Versicherungsindustrie
die Gelder zur Verfügung hätte die mehr
investieren könnte warum das in
Deutschland noch nicht passiert ist ein
bisschen Puzzle in Frankreich vor
freundsprache eben Frankreich an wo die
Regulierung eigentlich ziemlich ähnlich
sind ist das sehr viel erfolgreicher
funktioniert das sehr viel besser es
liegt also nicht an irgendwelchen Risiko
kapitalbewertungen und Gewichtung es
passiert einfach nicht die deutsche
Versicherungsindustrie hat sich
entschieden diesen Schritt zu gehen oder
so nicht möglich gemacht da zu
investieren und da müssen wir ganz
dringend Anstöße geben und das sind halt
wirklich genau wie Sie gesagt haben
kulturelle Anstöße das wäre anders
drüber nachdenken wie wir das die Gelder
investieren in in Risiko Kapital das
natürlich wenn breit gestreut
hoffentlich weniger Risiko ist und
deutlich höhere Erträge für alle
ja Frau Freund nickt zustimmt ich habe
ja auch noch eine Frage aus der
Community ganz spezifisch an sie sind
jetzt mal ganz schön unser
Praxisbeispiel im Prinzip zu dem Thema
was wir besprechen hier fragt er andere
Male ich auf Youtube in wie vielen
Jahren halten Sie es für realisierbar
die Kernfusion als nachhaltige
Energiequelle in Deutschland zu
etablieren vielleicht jetzt auch unter
der Prämisse die wir gehört haben dass
Deutschland aktuell für diesen Schritt
in dem sie sich befinden nicht der
geeignete Wirtschaftsstandort ist
also unser Ziel ist es in zehn Jahren
kommerzielle Kraftwerke zu bauen und
dieses Ziel halte ich durchaus für
erreichbar gerade mit dem Schritt den
wir jetzt gegangen sind mit der mit der
testernlage den wir bauen jetzt muss man
auch dazu wieder sagen damit wir das in
Deutschland sehen werden brauchen wir
neben all den Instrumenten die wir
gerade gesehen haben gibt's hier auch
noch ein regulatorisches Thema hier sind
die USA und England schon einen Schritt
voraus die sehr klar ein regulatorisches
Rahmenwerk schon herausgebracht haben
das sagt das Kernfusion nicht wie
Kernspaltung reguliert werden wird also
mit ist sondern wie
Teilchenbeschleuniger also ganz andere
Anforderungen einfach weil es kein
kettenreaktionsrisiko gibt und keinen
langgewinn radioaktiven Abfall gibt und
das ist natürlich ein extreme
Planungssicherheit für Unternehmen die
auf diesen Ländern in diesen Ländern
aktiv sind das heißt auch hier brauchen
wir in Deutschland in Europa
regulatorische Sicherheit und ein
regulatorisches Rahmenwerk was natürlich
im besten Fall in die gleiche Richtung
gehen würde und auch regulieren würde
dass das Kernfusion nicht wie
Kernspaltung reguliert wird ansonsten
falls dieser Schritt kommen würde werden
wir wahrscheinlich auch nach der
Einführung die ersten 10 20 Jahre keine
Fusionskraftwerke in Europa sehen
ja Thema deutsche Bürokratie das sagt
wahrscheinlich jedem was wird dir schon
sehr lange hoch gehalten vielleicht im
Alltag auch mal belächelt Frau Malm in
dir die deutsche Bürokratie ist das auch
ein Hindernis auf diesem Weg den wir da
wirtschaftlich eigentlich gehen sollten
ja ein deutliches Jahr ich möchte
allerdings schon damit anfangen zu sagen
dass wie immer nicht alles schlecht ist
dass es nicht schwarz weiß ist und dass
wir in Deutschland über Risiken
gründlich nachdenken dass wir
Mitnahmeeffekte verhindern wollen dass
wir genau überprüfen wollen was wir da
vorne das hat sicherlich auch viele
Vorteile gehabt also wenn ich mir jetzt
anschaue wie Tesla hier mit dem mit dem
autonomen treiben
Kalifornien umgegangen ist dass das
hätte wäre Deutschland nicht passiert
solche Risiken werden nicht eingegangen
und das wäre auch teilweise sehr gut so
gewesen allerdings ist es ganz klar eine
der Riesen Hürden und das Drama ist ja
die Tragödie ist ja dass das irgendwie
heben können ja wir müssen uns jetzt
einfach hinsetzen und ganz konkret
anschauen wo können wir
entbürokratisieren wo können wir
Prozesse beschleunigen wo können wir
Planungssicherheit schaffen gerade sagte
das geht wissen die Gerichte rein wo
können wir Gerichtsverfahren
beschleunigen all das macht Deutschland
zu einem Land das ein attraktiver
Standort ist
das ist wirklich was an dem wir ganz
einfach arbeiten können einen Gaspreisen
und Strompreisen können wir so schnell
nichts drehen aber daran können wir was
drehen ich habe mir wie viele nach der
nach dem sehr schnellen Verfahren mit
den aventi Terminals die dann doch auf
einmal in Deutschland ankamen und und
uns halten durch die Energiekrise zu
kommen sehr große Hoffnung gemacht dass
das ähm Deutschland Tempo wieder Scholz
glaube ich immer sagt sich in der Tat
auf viele andere Bereiche auswirken wird
ich hoffe dass das eine Priorität bleibt
das ist nicht immer das muss sexy Thema
aber das ist die Schraube an dem wir an
der wir drehen können
ja und wenn wir jetzt ähm Vergleich
Wirtschaftsstandort Deutschland an USA
noch mal quasi ähm auf die ganz große
Brille aufsetzen dann ist ja auch ein
Trend äh das immer mehr Unternehmen den
Börsengang in den USA Wagen und nicht
mehr in Deutschland Frau Freund jetzt
mal in die Zukunft gesprochen was müsste
denn passieren dass Ihr Unternehmen
irgendwann mal in Deutschland an die
Börse geht und nicht in den USA
das sind natürlich jetzt schon fünf
Schritte in die Zukunft ich hoffe dass
wir den nächsten Schritt und zwar den
Bau des Prototypen dann wieder in
Deutschland umsetzen können und dass wir
hier für die richtigen Instrumente in
Deutschland auf die Beine gestellt
bekommen beim Börsengang sprechen Sie
natürlich auch ein wichtiges Thema an
und ich glaube hier ist auf der einen
Seite auch das Thema Kapital
Verfügbarkeit in Europa wie vor mal mit
dir gerade gesagt hat das bringt am Ende
viele junge Unternehmen dann doch zu
einem Börsengang in den USA und ich
glaube das zweite Thema ist dass mir
zumindest kein erfolgreicher Fall einer
pre-venuefirma also einer Firma noch
bevor sie Umsätze generiert einer
erfolgreicher Börsengang hier in
Deutschland bekannt wäre aber es in den
USA diese Beispiele gibt und als Firma
als Geschäftsführerin einer Firma würde
ich natürlich immer schauen
widerstichwort Rahmenbedingungen
Planbarkeit wo sehe ich dass es
erfolgreiche Beispiele in der
Vergangenheit gab und würde
wahrscheinlich dann auch so einen Ort
suchen das heißt hier ist mein ganz
klarer Appell dass wir schauen müssen
dass wir erfolgreiche Beispiele hier in
Deutschland auf die Beine stellen
Kapital Verfügbarkeit ist ein riesen
Thema die hat gerade die Versicherung
z.B angesprochen ich glaube es ist
Mangel nicht an Kapital in Europa es
muss aber die richtigen Anreize aus der
Politik geben dass dieses Kapital dann
auch an den richtigen Stellen investiert
wird und aus meiner Sicht ist eine
Investition in die Texte sicherlich eine
sehr gute Investition für den
Industriestandort Deutschland
ich habe hier noch mal eine Frage aus
der Community an sie Frau malmedia noch
mal die Frage warum dieser
Innovationstransfer in den USA offenbar
besser klappt und ob vielleicht auch die
deutsche exzellenzstrategie was damit zu
tun hat
also
wie vorhin schon erwähnt hatte und sie
verfolgt ja auch bestätigt hat dieses
Jahr im im Anfangsstadium dieses
Transfers gar nicht so schlecht aus also
wenn wir diese
unternehmensorientierten ähm jungen
Studenten nächste Generation Leute
Erfinder die die schlaue Idee ausgedacht
haben uns anschauen dann kriegen sie
halt durch dieses seed fahren links oder
erwähnt eigentlich ganz guter Anstöße
auch inzwischen besseres Mentoring das
könnte vielleicht noch etwas verstärkt
werden
incubators aber wir haben auch schon
seit Jahrzehnten vielleicht 100 eine
Struktur mit dem
max-planck-gesellschaften
Instituten die diese sowohl die
Grundlagenforschung als auch die
Umsetzung von innovativen Ideen in die
Praxis ganz explizit fördert also da
sehe ich jetzt nicht mal unbedingt so
den den Nachholbedarf es ist meines das
ist auch nicht auf der Seite der
Unternehmen ich habe zwei und wenn ein
bisschen geschimpft ist dass dass die
großen Unternehmen vielleicht etwas zu
lange an alten Kunden festgehalten haben
im Beispiel der Automobilindustrie aber
da kommt vielleicht die
finanzwirtschaftlerin in mir raus ich
sehe das Hauptproblem wirklich in diesem
mittleren Teil der Finanzierung wo die
Unternehmen dann halt wenn Sie
erfolgreich sind wenn sie mehr als 150
Millionen brauchen nach Geld jemand
suchen die hier nicht finden die
unterstützen Dich finden auch die die
Betreuung also wie sie ist ja auch
gleichzeitig eine Betreuung bei den
weiteren Schritten nicht finden und dann
an ausländische
Gelehrte Kontakt zum Ausland da dann ist
es sehr viel einfacher den Exit also das
an die Börse gehen was erwähnt haben im
Ausland zu machen und dann haben wir
halt das Human Kapital verloren und die
ganz Investition verloren ist findet
woanders statt also meines Erachtens ist
es mehr die finanzielle Schraube an der
ich da drehen möchte also ich denke dass
wir großes Potenzial haben und das ist
wie sie vorhin gesagt haben wirklich
teilweise einfach eine kulturelle Frage
genauso wie uns als Bevölkerung ein
bisschen die Aktienkultur die direkt
Investitionen in Kapitalmarkt fehlt ist
das jetzt auf einer höheren Ebene auch
etwas was zum Beispiel an diesem Fall
Beispiel Versicherungsindustrie in
Deutschland wirklich Nachholbedarf hat
im Vergleich zu anderen Länder
und zum Abschluss habe ich noch eine
politische Frage die vielleicht ganz gut
unsere Anfangsfrage noch mal einfängt
nämlich ob Olaf Scholz diese Krise
gerade ignoriert dazu fragt sich YouTube
User Felix warum behaupten eigentlich
die meisten dass die aktuellen Probleme
an der Amt liegen obwohl aktuelle
Probleme auch durch die Politik von
Angela Merkel verursacht worden
dir können Sie uns das Einschätzen
inwiefern kann man jetzt die
Ampelkoalition alleine dafür
verantwortlich machen und inwiefern hat
Angela Merkels Politik auch diese
Wirtschaft und auch vielleicht das
kulturelle Umfeld in Deutschland dahin
geprägt
also bevor ich mich da zwischen der
Merkel Regierungen derzeitigen
ampelregierung entscheide und
schuldweise würde ich zunächst mal
festhalten das genau wie der User gesagt
hat die wirtschaftlichen Umstände
eigentlich ganz entscheidend sind ja
Corona hat keiner von beiden verursacht
und die in den äh Angriff auf die
Ukraine schon überhaupt nicht insofern
ist es leider in Deutschland wie in
allen anderen Ländern so dass wir sehr
schnell dazu neigen der Politik etwas
zuzuschreiben was in Wirklichkeit
wirtschaftliche Umstände konjunkturelle
oder strukturelle sind also das das wird
zunächst mal meine erste Antwort darauf
dann ist natürlich immer die Frage wie
reagiert man da drauf
ehrlich gesagt gebe ich beiden Regierung
relativ gute Noten also was in Wien und
unter Merkel die Reaktion auf Corona
passiert ist und wie jetzt die Reaktion
auf die Energiekrise
umgesetzt wurde das war sehr viel
erfolgreicher als die meisten Stimmen
das am Anfang dieser dieser Krisen
erwartet hatten insofern stimme ich dem
äh dem dem dem Kommentator dazu dass
diese einseitige kausale Beziehung auf
die Ampelkoalition sehr viel geleitet
ist aber ich denke es ist so ähnlich ähm
was die merkelregierung bitte
Frau Freund ich schließe unsere Runde
jetzt an dieser Stelle und bedanke mich
ganz herzlich bei Ihnen für ihre
Fachkenntnisse für ihre insights aus der
Praxis vielen Dank
ja ihr merkt schon es ist ein wahnsinnig
komplexes Thema in denen dass man ganz
viele Dinge mit einem beziehen kann die
Wissenschaft die Erfahrung aus der
Praxis die politische Dimension die aber
wie Frau Namen dir auch gerade noch mal
gesagt hat nur eine Variable ist ähm
denn da sind auch ganz viele Dinge auf
die die Politik erstmal keinen Einfluss
hat wie es weitergeht mit der Lage der
deutschen Wirtschaft ob es irgendwann
wieder ein Wirtschaftswachstum geben
wird das in Deutschland prognostiziert
wird wir bleiben auf jeden Fall für euch
dran und hier werdet ihr es erfahren
vielen Dank für eure Fragen und einen
schönen Abend noch